les combats ont pris fin il y a quatre
ou cinq jours ici les ruines fument
toujours et les champs continuent de
brûler
si ce n'était de cet écran de fumée des
chars et des voitures marquées du Z
symbole de l'armée russe ici des restes
de projectiles immunitions qui polluent
le sol on devinerait mal les combats des
derniers jours le capitaine a rechenko
de la 60e brigade assure qu'ils ont
pourtant été rude
ils ont fait preuve de courage ici ils
ont tenu jusqu'au bout dit-il le plus
difficile a été de briser leur première
ligne de défense mais après on les a
juste pourchassés alors qu'il se sauver
à la lisière du bois sur 30 km
ils ont profité du temps plus vieux pour
surprendre l'ennemi dit-il mais surtout
de ces hommes maestro psycho zolutné est
cramé leur nom de code font partie d'une
unité de reconnaissance du 98e bataillon
de la 60e brigade leur tâche infiltrer
les positions russes pour identifier des
cibles
alors souvent on passe aussi à l'assaut
ce n'est pas que de la reconnaissance
non quand on leur demande ce qu'ils ont
sacrifié depuis le début de la guerre il
se taisent et baisse le regard ils ont
perdu 6 de leurs compagnons d'armes
depuis le début de la contrefensive dans
le sud
pas que c'est difficile tu obéis aux
ordres c'est tout si le soldat tu sais
que des enfants que des vieillards sont
derrière toi et quand tu libères un
village tu vois l'émotion que les gens
ressentent ça justifie tout
dans plus d'une vingtaine de villages
maintenant libérés de l'occupation russe
ces émotions vont du soulagement à
l'incrédulité en passant par la haine
celle de ceux qui ont imposé la peur et
le sadisme il n'y a pas que les maisons
qui sont détruites les gens sont brisés
des victoires Copito il raconte avoir
été emprisonné et torturé dans sa propre
cave par des soldats russes pendant 3
semaines en mars dernier
peut-être à cause de l'adrénaline le
pire c'est qu'il me brisait
psychologiquement après ces trois
semaines à être brûlé aux chevilles
c'est geôlier s'en sont désintéressés et
sont partis plus loin il a fui
crestchenika dans un convoi humanitaire
à la première occasion si lui est revenu
avec l'arrivée des soldats ukrainiens
en ont profité pour enfin fuir les deux
voisines ont sauté sur les premiers
soldats Ukrainiens venus ils les ont
conduits avec leurs jeunes enfants le
visage rongé par les piqûres de
moustiques dans un centre d'hébergement
à cri au centre du pays
pendant que les 8 derniers mois passés
avec la rage au cœur la fin au ventre
Maxime son fils se prend la tête sans
arrêt
le garçon est comme ça depuis le choc
des bombardements dit-elle enfermés dans
son cauchemar tout est devenu agression
pour lui il ne parle plus
bombardements il a arrêté de parler
racontola il bégayait un peu il a peur
de tout maintenant on entre dans une
pièce il a peur s'il y a beaucoup de
monde il a peur nos militaires il en a
peur il ne comprend pas que cela sent
bon
les repas chauds et les soins que les
femmes reçoivent enfin ne les empêche
pas d'avoir le mal de ce qu'elles ont
laissé au village de ceux qui n'ont pas
pu les suivre
je ne peux pas voir mon enfant dit
tétiana ma plus vieille est comme ce
garçon mais elle est chez mes parents
ils vivent de l'autre côté du pont qui a
été détruit je ne peux pas y aller je
l'ai vu par internet pour la première
fois en 7 mois hier je ne savais pas
quoi lui dire les blessures morales
infligées à leur famille les jeunes
femmes ne les pardonnent pas elles ont
partagé la route qui les a menées
jusqu'ici avec un construire russe
prisonniers des Ukrainiens qui les
conduisaient soudainement désarmées il
leur paraissait bête et fragile olyna
n'avait qu'une envie lui crever les yeux
puissante et qu'ils allaient prendre
tout ce qu'il voulait dit là mais notre
petit armée les abattues quand ils ont
commencé à fuir les gens ordinaires
comme nous des Patriotes ont commencé à
les attraper à les empoisonner à les
battre
un patriote c'est comme ça que se décrit
Nikita c'est volontairement que le jeûne
s'est joint l'armée il est au front
depuis une semaine à peine en lui
enseigné l'artillerie mais sans
équipement il se retrouve sur le champ
de bataille armé d'un fusil
de l'artillerie aux Russes alors
peut-être dit-il mais pour l'instant je
suis dans l'infanterie on le dit souvent
la blague mais c'est une blague qui peut
souvent être vrai la semaine a été
éprouvante trop de brides d'équipement
des usées trop de blessés inutiles
tant qu'il garde le moral l'impossible
croit-il restera à portée de son arme